das kann doch gar nicht sein also die
älteren sterne unserer milchstraße sind
total dynamisch und bewegen sich nicht
nur stärker auf und ab als die jüngeren
sterne sondern rasen auch schneller nach
außen zu dieser verblüffenden erkenntnis
kommt jetzt ein britischer astronomie
team und liefert auch gleich eine
spannende erklärung dafür kriegst um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonnenten
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen obwohl die milchstraße ja
quasi unsere kosmische heimat ist wissen
wir längst noch nicht alles über sie das
komplexe gebilde besteht aus mehr als
250 milliarden sternen ausgelegten
gaswolken und anderen kosmischen
objekten bekannt ist auch dass die
milchstraße wohl vor rund zehn
milliarden jahren eine gewaltige
kollision erlebt haben muss erst vor
kurzem hat ein forschungsteam dann durch
die positionsbestimmung von hunderten
speziellen sternen eine dreidimensionale
kabel der milchstraße erstellt und die
hat eine wirklich spannende besonderheit
unserer galaxie enthüllt anders als
bisher angenommen ist die milchstraße
nicht eben also keine ebene
stattdessen handelt es sich bei der
milchstraße um eine besondere
spiralgalaxien dabei wechseln die
äußeren regionen also je nachdem wo man
sieht unserer milchstraße von der haupt
ebene der sterne scheibe auf der einen
seite nach oben und auf der anderen
seite nach unten bogenförmig schaut man
sich die milchstraße in diesem modell
von der seite an ist sie leicht s förmig
jetzt liefert ein britisches us promi
team eine weitere verblüffende
erkenntnis über die eigenarten unserer
kosmischen heime die fachleute hatten
das alter die geschwindigkeiten und
bewegung von mehr als 65.000 sternen
genauer analysiert und dabei
festgestellt dass sich vor allem die
älteren sternen ganz anders bewegen als
man bislang angenommen hatte zum einen
ist ihr tempo vom zentrum hin und von
ihm weg deutlich höher als bei jüngeren
sternen aber nicht nur dass die
populationen der älteren stern bewegen
sich auch stärker in verschiedene
richtungen sogar so weit dass sie dabei
teilweise über die galaxie ebene hinweg
wandern die analyse der fachleute zeigt
dass sich die jünger und sterne dagegen
eher im inneren bereich der galaxie
aufhalten und sich dort auch so bewegen
wie es bisherige modelle vorausgesagt
hatten sie bewegen sich unter anderem
auf ihrer kreisbahn
um das galaktische zentrum herum
schneller als die älteren sternen
die studie basiert unter anderem auf
daten die gaia eine weltraumsonde der
europäischen weltraumorganisation
gesammelt hatte die überraschende
dynamik der älteren sterne erklären die
fachleute mit turbulenzen dazu tech
mekkas der an der studie beteiligt war
wir glauben dass ältere sterne deshalb
aktiver sind weil sie in einer periode
gebildet wurden in der unseren ganzen
oft viel unruhiger war als heute damals
gab es eine menge stern bildung und
viele turbulenzen durch gase und
kleinere satellitengalaxien so wurden
offensichtlich also nicht nur wichtige
strukturen der milchstraße geformt diese
prozesse führten wohl auch dazu dass
älteren sternen ein zusätzlicher schub
mitgegeben wurde eine super spannende
erkenntnisse für die fachwelt die beiden
weiteren verständnis der milchstraße
eine entscheidende rolle spielen könnte
dazu schreibt das autorenteam die
spezifische art in der sich die sterne
bewegen verrät uns welche dieser
prozesse bei der bildung der stern
schäumen dominant traten dabei sind
viele verschiedene prozesse am werk und
sie zu entwirren hilft uns dabei ein
besseres bild der geschichte unserer
galaxie zu bekommen wie leer ist das
universum anklicken anschauen und
neugier zone und breaking lab abonnieren
super kanäle bei uns in unserem kleinen
wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054 bis dann
bleibt dran